ray Ratto NBC Sports Bay Area covering
the Warriors kind enough to join us
again this morning ray good morning hi
mom good
did you lose confidence at all last
night in the Warriors well first of all
I can fix your LeBron headline problem
okay
it is Cavs 50 to help LeBron beat
Celtics just get to the lead
no I didn't and it wasn't a question of
confidence because the one thing that
I've always thought was wrong with this
Houston team especially once Paul went
out is that they were asking 40-plus
minutes of too many guys and the the 27
missed threes in a row I mean true Sam
Hank you couldn't get the Sixers to ever
do that but almost all of those were
short and off line and that tells me
they got tired about the middle of the
second quarter I didn't
I thought the Warriors might have a
decent third quarter I didn't think
they'd win it by 18 but you know they're
they're sort of lean on peripatetic
sharks once they smell blood they call
all their friends and that's how that
ended up you know it's just it's you
know Rockets basically just didn't have
enough cards to play in game 6 and 7
that's why that's why the Paul thing was
so damaging they they played guys 42 and
43 minutes night after night after night
and you could tell it was bothering them
throughout the series because they
missed 190 threes in the seven games
they shot 28% and that's what they do
they are a 3-point shooting team and if
you can't do the best thing you do
eventually you die I mentioned this in
the opening to the show it always feels
like Steph Curry's threes hurt a little
more count a little more it's almost
like you get the guy who's a great
dunker and he dunks on somebody now it's
the three-point shot or breaking
somebody's ankles but do you get that
feeling that Steph can
demoralize you more than a klay Thompson
3 or Kevin Durant or draymond Green see
I actually think it's just the opposite
I think the Thompson threes demoralize
you more because you're expecting curry
to go off when when Thompson starts
throwing in now you go well ok here's
two guys we can't guard and now we're
completely screwed the curry stuff you
sort of you're sort of surprised by
shoots poorly but you expect him to have
little runs you know where you know he
can he can sort of put you on edge but
Thompson is almost like sort of you've
been punched in the head now you're
going to get hit in the back of the head
with a shovel and then you're done so I
kind of feel differently about that but
you know in sort of you know pick your
poison you know either way you're gonna
die handicap this team this Golden State
team because I thought last night was
just sort of a microcosm of the entire
season where you're just not quite sure
but then it feels like you should be
sure at the very end of the game so what
do you expect in the finalists I expect
them to be bored a fair amount of the
time in the first half because that's
who they become they you know they
cannot beat the idealized version of
themselves from 2015 and even 2017 and
they're all regular season was about
well got one one when do we have to kick
it into gear when do we a no and even
through this series they had full halves
where they didn't kick it into gear game
six the first half they were awful game
seven I thought Steve Kerr was going to
throw up on the sidelines and yet they
just go out we're gonna be there again
we're gonna be there in the end we're
gonna be there again I don't see
anything that is materially different
about Cleveland than Houston except for
the fact that LeBron James is better
than James Harden I still see a team
that short-handed especially if Kevin
Love isn't playing and they Cleveland
doesn't even have a version of Clint
capela so I think you know what Brian is
going to go nuts and everybody's going
to you know continue to have the tedious
argument about whether he's better than
Michael Jordan but there is
much of an argument about where the
calves are better than the Warriors
because they're clearly yacht I mean the
line for for Thursday's game it is the
highest in NBA Finals first game history
I mean in some places they're 10 to 1
favorites to win the series those are
ridiculous numbers I mean there's off
the charts stupid and I just think
that's that that's the issue here is it
Cleveland doesn't have enough things
other than LeBron to make the warrior
sort of shake themselves out of their
occasional tour which is and we'll get
around to killing them we'll get around
killing them and then they do but it's
also degree of difficulty it's it's
almost as if I watch the first half and
I'm going they let it set they'll set up
a hurdle here or potholes here land
mines and then let's see if we can
navigate them alright ready
let's go out for the third quarter do
you think they and maybe this is what
you're saying that they get bored and
then they go okay what are we down
fifteen all right who wants to start
okay Steph you start it's funny because
all year long you know they'd have games
like this would it be awful for a half
and then at the end of the game they'd
all acknowledge how awful they were he
says well that's going to stop that's
going to stop and I think part of it is
I mean it's not like they're trying to
be bad in the first half because they
find it amusing
I just think they find it harder to
focus for as long as they have in past
years and I think it's because in the
back of their minds they know they're
better and when you know you're better
it is human nature to say well we'll get
around to finishing this off and you
know it's that's what I thought last
night it's the middle of the second
quarter they're down 11 and then Houston
starts missing those three-pointers
because that's when the streak started
middle of the second quarter that's when
they started missing all those shots and
when you want to finish off the Warriors
you don't go into the locker room up 11
at half or up 11 in the early third
quarter you have to be of 23 and
Houston couldn't do that because their
whole series was get off fast and then
try to hold on and without Crispo you
can't Chuck an array Ratto NBC Sports
Bay Area do you remember a time when we
were debating if Michael Jordan was the
greatest player in basketball like who
was the greatest player before that that
that we had this silly argument do you
remember that probably probably magic
yeah I remember it we always do that but
the greatest of all time magic wasn't
considered we're talking about Michael
is the greatest all-time so LeBron is he
as good as Michael I was just curious
who Michael was compared to greatest of
all time I don't know that there ever
was one to this extended stretch only
because the only person you could look
at his Chamberlain and most of
Chamberlain's greatness was done in the
pre television era
I mean his you know if you hold up his
basketball reference page and put it
next to Jordans you go my god Wilt
Chamberlain is unbelievable but nobody
ever saw him yeah at the time when it
was necessary to see him with Jordan it
sort of become King became a de facto
you know settled argument because there
was nobody that you could point to and
say somebody's better than this guy I
mean you know maybe you could throw up
Larry Bird if you lived in the Northeast
and people in LA absolutely did throw up
Magic Johnson it was not yeah maybe it
wasn't a fair fight and maybe the real
argument would have been Jordan or
Kareem but it's hard to compare guys it
would at different positions so I think
you know Jordan became the de facto best
ever in part because the one guy that
you could hold up would be Chamberlain
and nobody nobody saw him enough and the
same thing with Bill Russell I mean
nobody's gonna get 11 rings and he was
an extraordinary player but again nobody
saw him enough I mean it's it's it's the
tyranny of technology yeah my
came along at the right time because
then you could see all of his games
whereas there was almost this
mythological field - Wilt Chamberlain
and Bill Russell and that can benefit
you to a certain point but then all of a
sudden you're seeing and you're not even
believing what you're seeing with Jordan
with Wilt Chamberlain like he scored a
hundred points in a game or Bill Russell
had 11 championships yeah but could he
do what Jordan was doing and so I was
just curious that why was I'm watching
last night I know this argument
discussions gonna come up this week on
these shows about LeBron and where is he
with Michael Jordan and I keep telling
people ray just enjoy what you see this
won't happen again this guy won't happen
again
Michael's not happening again will it's
not happening again and neither is Bill
Russell but we get caught up in this
petty argument when you can't win
there's nothing that says well this is
the reason why or that's the reason why
and I think what happens is we get we
miss really what's right in front of us
and you know even with people
complaining about Cavs Warriors again
wouldn't you give anything to have
another Lakers Celtics in the 80s where
they went at it one more time
good god that would have been awesome I
never got tired of great matchups well
see I think your answer should be when
they start talking about LeBron versus
Michael is to just say shut up and hit
the guy in the throat that way you don't
have to hear the argument anymore
because it is a stupid argument because
it's not designed to settle anything
it's about letting the person making the
argument say the same things over and
over again until you want to hit I hear
your argument give me your thorax
they're done and if you hit enough
people
they'll stop bothering you with it I
like it but is that a misdemeanor Ray I
think if you plead your case properly
you might get an NEA grant out of it
[Music]
thank you Ray well we'll talk to you
again soon okay take care all right
that's Ray Ratto NBC
Sports Bay Area one of our favorites for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]